yo once who was had in your oldest DJ
mugs live from La man make sure to check
me out on bootleg cave podcast
in here one of the greatest producers to
ever live ladies and gentlemen doesn't
do a lot of interviews so I feel very
privileged to be sitting down with DJ
mugs what's happening Brother welcome
man thanks for having me man hell yeah
soul assassin's three Death Valley is
out yeah man and what a track listing
wow man some [__] on there some
[__] on there for real yeah
some of my favorite new rappers man like
you know Bode James shout out to bodies
you got Ghostface on there yeah oh yeah
then we got some of the classics and
[__] yeah ghost and gun shout out to TF
man I was gonna say like it's crazy
because I remember
The Source uh uh advertisements for the
very first Soul assassins album which
was what 97 or 98.7 Yeah man so like
Fast Forward uh I don't even want to
talk about how many years that is
because it'll age you and me a lot but
for you like what's what is changed
about putting together a soul assassins
album after you know 25 years later
whatever it is
um and what kind of still fuels you to
be so passionate about this [__] because
you were active still to this day you
you know you're always drop in projects
joint projects working with
up-and-coming artists man yeah um part
one was um
back then it was pre-mixtapes before
mixtapes got really crazy so doing a
record like this was something unique
you know what I mean there was only a
few [__] doing that where I
just a lot of people was asking me to do
tracks for them for their albums and I
was like man I'm good man I just rather
just build my group and do my [__] but
I'm you all can come and be on my [__]
then once the mixtape Eric kicked off
everything was just mixtapes so then it
was just
it was was nothing's really special
about making these records no more
because you can go get a fly ass mixtape
yeah so I was like I don't think I'm
gonna do another one
so I just I record all the time so
recording the homies come through record
record stacking songs stacking songs and
I was like I got some [__] right here
what am I gonna do
and I was like I've had three or four
different ideas of the way to put it out
and then um I was just gonna probably
drop a song every two months for the
next three years and then gold watch
came through and I was like yo I need
you to help me figure something out man
I need to build something visually for
this record because I don't feel like
just doing um videos yeah the video I
saw that I only saw the trailer but the
trailer looked like a [__]
full-fledged cinematic experience 100
and I was like I'm tired of videos man
what can we do bro because I'm not
putting this record on I was like let's
let's build something that's like 10 15
minutes long he's like man that's a
that's that's gonna be hard and I was
like you know [__]
and um we started we should we shot and
um pre-prep for like a month we ended up
shooting in Death Valley
um Oakland San Francisco
Vegas LA and ended up being a 34 Minute
movie
crazy yeah we shot videos we shot music
videos and they're in the movie on the
TV like in the Trap House mayhem's
videos on the TV in the trap house
Rockmart she's building a bomb
that's crazy and um you know his video
I'm watching his video
in in my house while he's building a
bomb in the video I'm holding the bomb
so it's psychedelic it's like I don't
know if you're familiar with
alejandroski so I compare more like a
jadorovski meets Pink Floyd with hip-hop
yeah it's crazy because I feel like not
like you said back in the day what you
did was unique and I feel like in
today's climate doing a 34 Minute like
mini movie is unique as well we've seen
like movies to go along with albums I
feel like people don't do that [__] no
more because they're like so worried
about like the microwavable attention
span of people instead of like yo let me
do something dope unique creative yeah I
did it for me man I can give a [__] you
know what I mean I did it all for me
like how can I keep myself entertained
yeah now can I do something just fun
just to get up and do everything some a
little challenging some I ain't done
before so that was the driving force
behind it for me yeah I didn't did
everything I've set out to do years ago
so you know just keep them just keep
tricking my brain and stretching myself
and having a good time doing this [__]
is that what keeps you going it's like
I'm doing this for me really like I'm
gonna do it for me but you know at the
same time man I love I love
the kind of music we make this
underground hip-hop [__] that it's
nothing different than I've always made
but you know I figured I can come here
now and just Champion what's going on
and just build build this culture and
make it bigger and stretch it make it
stronger you know what I mean sure
Inspire the youth and then also give
guidance and and and let them tap into
my fan base you know what I mean and
grab some of these youngsters and like
show them show them the way yeah it's
been dope to see like your run it just
continue and I I just had this talk with
Al recently because I'm always trying to
push rappers to do albums with
Alchemists that you know I just did this
with Jadakiss on the podcast I was like
why haven't you done a whole album with
Alchemist no [__] all right crazy that'd
be crazy but like to see you like you
know you're like like always working
with artists and like doing like
full-fledged like bodies of work whether
it's like Jay worthy or Mayhem Lauren
like you're very much like you know it
feels like you're still in your Peak and
you're still like
like you said the the underground [__]
has changed over the years the
quote-unquote underground hip-hop [__]
has definitely changed from what like it
might have been in like 2000 2001 or
whatever but like you're still like
fully engaged and like pushing that
culture and like to me that's that's
very dope because you know just from a
DJ perspective like I find the little
things that keep me still like motivated
and engaged to try to like still listen
to new artists you know what I mean and
and um so it's just dope to see you
still you know fully [__] in it bro
yeah man I'm you know just having a good
time man and you know just to be able to
just hang out and kick it with the
homies and um talk some [__] you know
what I mean what was the uh the homage
to Death Valley why so so assassin's
three Death Valley on this because
that's the title of the movie okay
that's the movie that's the 34 Minute
movie that comes with it it's Death
Valley you know it's the hottest [__]
place on Earth it is you know what I'm
saying so and it's you know and one of
the things in the movies I left LA to
get away from the heat
um you know go to Death Valley yeah it's
ironic right it's very ironic sure what
was uh for you because you know there's
always so many
when you have so many moving Parts on a
body of work when it comes to getting an
artist to like uh sign off on stuff you
have to deal with that kind of stuff
yeah every you know a lot of everybody
on this record off I have relationships
with them in the past you know so it was
pretty easy man it was pretty this this
record was pretty easy there was nothing
nothing crazy
yeah and also like a lot of guys are
independent right and they run in the
game a little bit different these days
like you know before dealing with majors
and dealing with labels and the
sign-offs and yeah the clearances and
the sample clearances she was a headache
you know a lot of times right now you
can be under the radar with a lot of
this [__] and a couple well I always
static selector always told me
because I was always like hey bro like
you guys clear clearly samples and he's
like man he's like look bro
he's like we just let [__] fly and if we
got to get it clear later that means
it's doing something basically if it's
under a certain number they ain't even
coming they didn't waste any time you
know right it's like and if it pops off
later then you know it's all good well
you know what sucks dude is like I don't
know if you've if you've experienced
this from your perspective but a lot of
like major label
artists or the labels will be very
specific to make sure like I I'll play
me something with no sample oh you don't
even want to clear samples anymore they
don't want to deal with this [__]
because they get hit hard man like like
a major is going to have to deal with
that [__] you know what I mean and
they're going to get hit because it's
amazing and they know they got bread so
Universal is reaching out as opposed to
like it freezes up the whole project you
know thank God now they just got to pull
a song or two off a Digital streaming
site instead of pulling all the records
off the [__] shelves that [__] was a
lot easier yeah imagine having to go to
Every record 500 000 records out of
Tower Records and you know all that [__]
did that happen before you seen it
happen with Biz you've seen it happen
with um
um truth hurts with Dre with the rock
himself that was a big Bollywood sample
yeah they put that [__] out and that
[__] got took that [__] off the show
that's a lot of [__] money to eat and
you're pulling a [__] million pieces
of vinyl off the shelves I have a random
question that I've always been curious
about
on Obie trice's album his first album
there's the song we all die one day Tony
Yayo starts off shouting out Soul
assassins and then in my opinion my
favorite Eminem verse ever
he shouts out be real said dog what was
the uh so was there any sort of Soul
assassin's connection with that song
like why was like Tony Yayo shouting
y'all out well here's what it was man so
that song was for the next Soul assassin
album
that's so that's what that song was for
we had started it at that time and um
you know and it was like I don't know if
I'm gonna do another one at the time and
then
um Obi was working on his record and
Paul's like hey can we use it for Obi
when it's time to do yours we'll do
another one and I was like absolutely no
problem just push it that way but that's
what that [__] was for crazy so that was
supposed to be other next solar
assassins oh wow when you heard Eminem's
verse on that song because I think I
truly think it's the best Eminem verse
ever and I also think it's murdered it I
think it's the most underrated song of
like that whole era of like G-Unit Shady
Records that song's so crazy
yeah we was managed by Paul for like six
seven years yeah yeah so at the time you
know he was rolling thick so everything
was in-house back then so we just had uh
names up here shout out to uh names yeah
I'm gonna go see him in New York next
week I love names he's great he's just
like kind of just vintage 90s like
disrespect yeah all day long man he told
me a story he was like yeah so you know
his lyrics are this dude I mean his
lyrics all the time are pretty crazy but
he was like Yeah man so like me and Paul
went to Spotify and we're in a room full
of like people played up the album
and he's like that's that was the one
time I felt really awkward because like
I have a song where I'm talking about
slapping the [__] out of women like if
they disrespect it and he's like you
could just see all the women in the
meeting just like be visual like like
visually uncomfortable and he's like I
had to stop and be like guys this is all
tongue-in-cheek like
like that's the best that's that early
2000s 90s energy man yeah man he came
with it on this [__] too boy it was good
to hear yeah for sure man uh what's your
favorite song on the album man
oh [__] I I like them all man I think I
went through periods or this was my
favorite then I recorded this one this
one's my favorite this was my favorite
so right now man I'm just you know out
here just enjoying the [__] record
yeah dude like like let's just be clear
you have Scarface on this album with
Freddie Gibbs you got EV Domo Genesis
Jay worthy tool I mean this is crazy
Method Man is Slick Rick
how do you get slick rick on a record in
2023 just be patient man just be just be
patient I reached out to you know it's
like pretty much man uh the homies all
came through I reached out and said Rick
we're doing this he's a fan yeah a fan
of mine and he should be here he he does
he plays jump around every night in the
show one of his favorite songs ever so
when I reached out and let him know what
I was doing he said yeah I got you
where's the beat gave him the beat
and I had Method Man on it already and
you know that was probably like two
years ago that song has been done I want
to say one of the first singles was the
record with uh be real uh ran and Q
right
um and I remember seeing that and being
like yo you don't see MC Ren's name
anywhere anymore nah like like that
that's a big deal to get him and Cube
together on a song in 2023. yeah yeah
yeah especially with be real like if you
just think about like La hip-hop like
that's a crazy comment that's what I was
thinking like what do we do with this
man like Bieber was on like where do we
go with this song right here and I was
just like yo let's get Cube and ran and
Trey and Snoop and uh Snoop is gonna do
it's just timing just timing you know I
mean I just wanted Dre to talk on the
intros he's like I got you at the time
and I was like I gotta turn this [__] in
now but I'll go okay give me next time
um for you man I feel like your
production style is so unique and it
it's like I feel like you you there's
producers these days I feel like have
kind of lost
the sense of like style at least the
bigger ones like I feel like a lot of
these guys's beats are kind of
interchangeable like you could tell me
that it was produced by this person or
this person like oh yeah but I feel like
DJ mugs your [__] is so like you have
your signature sound like and I'm just
curious like when you first started
making beats what was like your
like where did you draw inspiration from
man like well first you know coming up
man you had to be different and having
your own style you was whack you
couldn't even use a sample somebody used
if you did use garbage
and uh you had to find your own samples
like original samples if somebody was
really digging yeah all those drums they
use those drums there was something
about that you know what I'm saying and
even for Cypress men the way we dressed
the slang we have our own slang you know
dress have our own look have our own
musical style so all that was important
he was whack he was a biter so for me
I was um
I grew up with a lot of classic rock
around and and my mom was in the Motown
so I had a lot of you know psychedelic
classic rock [__] influences Led
Zeppelin Jimi Hendrix but with hip hop
Run DMC LL Cool J Public Enemy and then
everything Molly Maul did every single
Molly mug that came out with back in
those days it seemed like he was
Reinventing the game with every [__]
single you know what I'm saying yeah
when you heard the bridge and then you
heard poison right and then you heard
raw and you was like what the [__] is
this [__] you know what I'm saying and
then uh everything Larry Smith did
you know um ultramagnetics boogie down
Productions like all that [__] right
there was like
all that like mixed up in gumbo and then
going through my filter and spit it back
out well I was gonna say too like you
were very like engaged with what was
going on in New York too for being a
West Coast guy yeah I grew up in New
York I moved here when I was 12 and then
I would always go back I would always
stay out there I had an apartment out
there for like 15 years yeah I would
always be in here you guys did the
second Cypress Hill album in New York
yeah because you know back then we
started you blow up and then it's just
too much [__] going on
friends [__] everybody hanging out I was
like let's go over here which was us
locked in a room by ourselves yeah I'm
sure you guys in La after that first
album the studio sessions yeah couldn't
help but be distracted and everybody was
you couldn't and um everybody was busy
you know there's all these new people
around and this and that and millions of
dollars you know and we're 21 years old
so it was like let's go to New York and
it's just us getting up going to the
studio
back to the crib back to the studio
that's all we did that shit's Fire Man
and we knocked that [__] out in a month
the record we knocked that record out of
the month the label was like we need
that [__] now so we went in and
knocked it out right quick I suppose the
first record took like three four years
it was a whole life you know up to that
point in the second one
I think we only did I think some of the
songs even came out before I think we
only did eight songs new ones because we
had um
um hand on the Glock had already came
out
uh hdk came out a white man can't jump
soundtrack yep you know I mean there was
a couple interludes on there so
you know some of that [__] had came out
already but that [__] was [__] and
then soundscam was brand new when that
record came out
oh yeah yeah yeah I forgot sound scan
wasn't around like just came out like in
between our first and second album
no it's crazy too because I just think
like in terms of like you know for
whatever reason I feel like somehow
Cypress Hill gets like overlooked when
we talk about like goat conversations
like greatest groups of all time I mean
I feel like if you grew up in in LA or
you grew up on the west coast you
understand but I feel like for whatever
reason you guys are not underrated but
somehow underrated does that make sense
like you guys are still doing festivals
it's I mean platinum records but I still
feel like for whatever reason like like
we got to bring up that name in the mix
more when we talk about the greatest
groups of all time right right
yeah man I don't know [__] I can give a
[__] you know I mean what we set out to
do we're doing it you know what I mean
so that's all I give a [__] about so how
did you end up uh getting a House of
Payne back in the day before because I I
you I know I know you guys had a little
falling out for a sec but it was an
accident man like I was dating this girl
that actually was cousins of everlast's
DJ and I would go over there and he'd be
at the crib and I'd be like all right
and the Cyprus demo the Cyprus we were
signed already but the album I had the
album on a red cassette and I gave it to
her but the album didn't come out for
six months
so the next time I went over there a
couple times Everlast was there he was
listening to the tape he's like oh we
got to get in the studio I was like nah
I'm good man
and after three or four times I was like
I was talking to be real and b-rolls
like man just [__] would [__] with him I
was like all right so I went in and put
your head out in the crib and I was like
okay this is cool then the homies was
bumping it and then I was like I got the
song called Jump Around
so I had already recorded it with
sunduby I recorded it with Daddy Freddie
from ragamuffin hip hop and I had a song
I had the hook
he came in and wrote the [__] and I was
like now rewrite it with that Cadence
right there and he wrote the [__] and
then we had the joint and to one of the
greatest party songs of all time shop
the deal man I know Funkmaster Flex
wanted to sign us at priority records
for like I think it was like 55 60 G's
he had special ed over there at the time
I didn't even know Funk Flex worked the
priority yeah crazy and then um it was
weird because Monica Lynn show for a
Tommy Boy wanted to sign us and um so I
went and had a meeting with her and she
was like she was Irish so she's like
this reminds me of my family this is
like my brothers would go to church
then they go to uh to the bar and get
drunk and fight
so she got it right off the bat you know
I mean so she signed us because she gave
us like 300 back then
and then uh I hooked him up with our
management the guys who did our our
pictures I hooked up with those guys and
and David Perez who did our video I'll
come up with them so it was pretty much
the formula so you kind of just say
here's our formula run with it run with
it and it worked and work with it like a
[__] like a [__] yo I
always wondered so there was like this
era um I'm really close with Dilated
Peoples and raqqa and Hyper science and
Baboo and obviously shout out I did the
best hell yeah I love those guys
um
they really opened my world or my taste
in another a whole nother way
um to like digging into like different
[__] that I was into at the time but I
remember as a kid there was the random
because you were close like you were
cool with Paul obviously right you're
cool with M but then there's like this
weird beef between like Dilated Peoples
Everlasting Eminem did you ever try to
like bring those guys together nah it
was weird man I think I think Everlast
from what I remember correctly you know
don't quote me here but I think ever
last seen M on the elevator and M just
didn't say nothing to him but M's like
he didn't look the same right and didn't
realize that he didn't realize who he
was right right and and was a [__]
Everlast fan you know from what I hear
so ever that's just you know I don't
know what happened then he wrote some
[__] about him yeah and then I remember
there was like the dilated [__] and then
evidence had a song called uh Searching
for Bobby Fischer so I was just
wondering because you were kind of like
it felt like I'm in Switzerland you
might have you know I don't know if
you're trying to put a call in none no I
just figured all that y'all [__] up
yeah you know [__] with them good
luck with that [__] man good luck I mean
like even why but um I don't even think
I heard the dilated song ever yeah there
was an Evidence song called Searching
for Bobby Fischer that was like I heard
that one no but I had um a Napster hit
yeah so yeah I brought Paul I remember
when I met Paul I flew him out to L.A to
meet with me and I had a barbecue um to
manage Cyprus and he came out here and
that's how I met Paul because Theo Theo
was my lawyer and I was like yo I need a
new manager bro
what year was this before um before um
rock superstar album so it was like 2099
yeah 99 and I was he's like yo I got
this this lawyer he's got an ear like me
and he's managing this artist Eminem and
didn't blow up here yeah
flew his ass out had a barbecue and
locked in with Paul what what was was it
labeled like why did you guys do a rap
Superstar and a rock superstar
difference because um check this out so
we was up at Columbia and you know now
we're going into the fifth album
so we'd go to the urban Department that
was after the album after Dr
greenthumber before after after that's
right okay it was like yeah that was
four that was the fifth album yeah so we
would go up to the label and was like
all right let's go this marketing plan I
go to the urban Department it was like
no no you guys are
you guys are alternative I know we ain't
so we go up to the other we go up to the
next floor and they was like oh no you
guys are the urban Department
and they don't work together and
everybody's passing the buck nobody
wanted to do their [__] job and I was
like you my [__] pieces of [__] check
this out I'm gonna give you all a rock
song and a rap song So now what's your
[__] excuse you got one you got one
so I did we had a song called can't get
the best of me and rap Superstar
and then I walked into the meeting with
Donnie Aina and he was like no this is
the single we're not doing rock song
with this is the single I'm putting all
the money behind this one I was like oh
[__] this ain't gonna work so I went in
the studio a couple days later and did
the remix for Box Superstar wow okay
gotta stop the interview real quick to
tell you about our good Folks at
Bluetooth baby that's right shout out to
Bluetooth man listen everyone's always
asking me does blue true work of course
it works because it has the same active
ingredient as Viagra and Cialis
it is Dick season out here bruh you know
what I'm saying you got to make sure
that dick is up to par you know you get
on that blue shoe and uh you're gonna
never like I mean I'm gonna be honest
like
you remember when Barry Bonds hit 70
home runs in a season and now they're
not letting them in the Hall of Fame
like you get off that Bluetooth they're
not gonna let you in the dick Hall of
Fame because it's cheating to be honest
you know what I'm saying so
bluetooth.com use the promo code bootleg
when you sign up now this is what's dope
about boochu because you want to know if
it works well they're gonna send you a
month for free
free Bluetooth in discrete packaging
delivered right to your door but you
have to use the promo code bootleg
bluetooth.com promo code bootleg
everything's online no doctor's office
visits no worrying about [__] having
a weird conversation with some [__]
about your [__] [__] no you
[__] bluetooth.com free month online
you don't even have to leave your
[__] apartment you don't have to
leave anywhere you just order it it
comes in the mail and then you know you
you just you know you get to work you
get to work all right so use that promo
code bootleg and get a free month of
blue chew also want to give a big shout
out to our good Folks at Odd Socks now
this is what's up about Odd Socks I'm
about to reach into my Odd Socks bag oh
man look Odd Socks they got
all of the [__] sick licenses
recently they locked down Coca-Cola
recently they locked down [__]
Transformers Saban Power Rangers we got
Yoo-hoo we got Sour Patch Kids
you know they got their Odd Socks Basics
and I'm telling you the most comfortable
socks in the world in the [__] world
all right and they can all be yours 20
off
20 off using the promo code bootleg if
you go to
oddsoxofficial.com the most comfortable
socks in the world
and they got draws and these draws are
amazing
these are this is this is a small just
so we're clear this is a small yeah
yeah chicks can wear these you know a
lot of chicks like wearing these booty
shorts around the crib and [__]
oddsocksofficial.com whatever you're
into they got the licensed WWE Scarface
[__] Breaking Bad whatever
autotoxofficial.com promo code bootleg
go over there get 20 off right now let's
get back to the interview
because coming from the radio side um
you know I've done radio my whole life
and
like you said there's some times where
there be a record
like uh there was a shots of my I have a
friend uh yellow wolf who had a song and
he put a song out um through Shady
called let's roll but Kid Rock was on
the hook
so he ran into that issue where he was
like a hip-hop artist but they're like
we don't know what to do with this
because you know it's like hip-hop
inspired but it's like we grew bigger
than hip-hop we just became our own
thing you know for sure we got so big
and and you know just harnessing that
rock and roll energy like I said Public
Enemy LL Run DMC Beastie Boys you know
what I mean and just coming from that
DNA from that side and um
so that's why I was like all right
here's something from both of y'all but
both of y'all can work and nobody can
complain and point fingers because the
record before they dropped the ball
because nobody was working it because
there was nobody wanted to do their
[__] job and pointing fingers so I
was like maybe this is the way the way
around and plus at that time you know I
was seeing all these whack [__]
that couldn't really rhyme but they was
rapping on Rock [__] where they sounded
decent you know and they was having
these big careers what year was that 99
2000 that was very much that was very
much the little era of that happening so
then I was you know and the other layer
that actually was me like oh yeah well
yeah I could do this [__] too yeah I'm
gonna do some rock [__] and then let me
bang on y'all [__] with this
[__] and then at the same time I
produced um
some [__] for Pearl Jam and Sonic Youth
crazy meaning some different rock bands
just to like let me see what I can do
and just I didn't know you did a tumble
program that's amazing shout out to
Pearl Jam yo you guys were a part of
like some of the crazy you know I always
tell people like there was festivals and
like people think of festivals these
days I feel like festivals in like the
late 90s early 2000s were like extremely
like
different yeah everything was different
the drugs were really out there the 90s
was the [__] man it was like it was one
of the best times period man I'm blessed
to be able to be in that time and then
also there's new time with all this new
technology for sure be able to be in an
analog world and be relevant in both but
I was gonna ask you what is like the
craziest crowd where you've you guys
were performing and you just looked out
and you were like what the [__] is going
on a couple times one of them was um was
the reading Festival we was the first
rap group to ever headline reading you
know 150 000. crazy looking at that and
then you know [__] with the
soccer chance and everybody with the
flags you know I mean it just looked
like some Revolution [__] and then it
was probably the 93 Woodstock 93
Woodstock five 150 000 people they had
to fly us into a helicopter because the
traffic was [__] five hour traffic
jams yeah I just watched the uh 99
Woodstock documentary which was looked
insane yeah 93 had to be crazy half a
million people half a million people bro
do you remember who was on the bill with
you uh I think Santana was after us and
because we were in and out there wasn't
even dress rooms we don't want y'all
hanging out just in and out yeah yeah
that's the only one I remember that's
[__] crazy man but Lollapalooza was
popping off back then smoking Groove
tours you know we did every smoking
grooves pretty much like five of them in
a row yo has there ever been like
somebody who's for whatever reason
escaped you in terms of someone you want
to work with because I feel like you've
worked with so many people
nah man I'm all about building man like
even with Cyprus I was like I never
wanted to be a producer where like my me
coming up was dependent on somebody
else's success right so I was like we
was always about build our own [__] no
guest appearances our own [__] do our
own shits you know what I mean and um
even even now I like I like newer
artists like working with it with a TF
you know like young Rome streets when I
first met Rome it was crazy you know oh
Rome's [__] boom you know pre-gazelle
todays and just finding these youngsters
I get more I got more excitement out of
that [__] you know but
um no I think it probably shot day you
know what I mean I'd want to work with
shot day but there's nobody that that
everybody anybody else I'm not really
tripping on did you ever get close to
doing anything with Hove
nah I never I don't even think I met him
crazy
that's crazy you would think
um for you because you've been doing a
lot of full collab albums I think back
to like one of the first producer
MC albums to me that I kind of just
heralded like very high in my life was
the first album you did with the the
Giza album It's a masterminds oh
Grandmasters Grand Masters yeah
um crazy body of work but you've still
done like you've done such a good job of
like doing these like fully you know
cohesive collaborative albums with other
artists I feel like a lot of people are
kind of doing that now as well 100 it
wasn't on it like that it wasn't on it
but you're kind of to me like you're the
first guy who really kind of did that
yeah they're doing versus records yeah
just uh um Asia Ill Bill we did back in
like what 2003 I think it was something
like that all four yeah me and jizz
always click man from the first day we
got in the lab we always clicked man and
it was just everything was smooth and
easy and you know we just kept
communicating all through the times you
know and um kept in touch and then we
then we got together into Grand Masters
but it was a weird time because at that
time it was right after Napster and the
[__] the whole ass fell out the music
industry so yeah we went from selling
under ground records 250 000 records to
sell in [__] 5 000 records so it was
before YouTube it was before Spotify it
was before Apple music yeah and then the
music the records weren't selling so you
was there was like this three or four
year period where we was like what the
[__] going on bro how do we how do we
monetize this nobody knew what was going
on yeah it was a weird ass time you know
what I mean so all I know is you just
stay consistent and just keep going
that's the one thing about my crew Man
From Me Al cartoon is Stefan Cypress we
just never stopped yeah you just never
stopped through it all I was gonna ask
you
um what is something that you've because
you're obviously uh you like you said
there was that point in time where
you've been a part of every
for the most part era of hip-hop in
terms of like the way the business is
right like you guys first came home with
soundscan hit now fast 80s like 80s my
first group you got to remember was 783
I didn't know that 1988 like my first
gold record was colors 783 Madman World
in the movie colors so I signed with 783
in 88 and we was um so we assigned to
rush management
Russell yeah and um we're doing Stadium
tours
we're open enough for salt and pepper
opening up for Hammer opening up for
Tony Tony Hammer yeah we was on the tour
with hammer Tony Tony and today what's
the MC Hammer toy like back then
stadiums crazy as [__] like I don't
think people understand like he was like
a [__] like pop star for real I have
an MC Hammer Barbie I'm talking I'm
talking you see my MCM or Barbie's
sitting down yeah talking you know 25
000 people a night and it's doing
stadiums mans you know and then um salt
and pepper Kwame was on the tour wow so
you know just being young and then I
would come back to Cyprus you know and
like I'm 18 19 and I was like yo
figuring this music [__] out fellas you
know what I mean so
783 really taught me about the music
business and I just brought all that
[__] knowledge back to Cyprus because
there was no Google or right no even
even to learn the DJ I had to go to the
club and watch the DJ and [__] listen
to the radio that's how I learned there
was no
scratch Academy or no [__] right none of
that you just had to really just learn
on the job let's watch and try to
remember and figure it out was I always
heard MC Hammer everyone always says
Hammer's like a real ass dude for real
for real like he's certified like but
but you also hear like he always had
like a big entourage with him oh he had
a big ass Entourage yeah like you you'd
come on the stage you know your little
hype man and and and maybe one little
dancer and he'd come out with like 16
dancers crazy you know I mean in a hype
man I was like little John back then
yeah like screaming and [__] talking
[__] so
yeah that was crazy man it was it was it
was a good experience to have those
tours you know and then with Cypress
you're like I already knew I already
knew what's gonna happen I was like the
success is waiting for us in the future
we just got to get to it fellas I was
going to say for you though
um how what are the things that you
could give advice to somebody who's an
independent artist maybe has like a
modest following how can they really
monetize music now because I feel like
it's not what it used to be streaming
doesn't pay the greatest well you got to
build a career man so I think I think
you got a tour you got to go do shows
man even if you're not getting paid you
go play in front of nine people yeah
always the Wonder plays the next time
you play in front of 20 next time you
play in front of 35 yeah you know in two
years it'll be 150 people there yeah so
the energy of the shows make sure you
have your merch and you join your
pop-ups and you're live on it and you're
live on social media talking to your
people you know and then doing your
streaming and um be consistent and I
think all that [__] together you you put
that together and you stay consistent
you build a career you know some
[__] just want to like
stream [__] and maybe they might get a
show in New York and then that's it
flashing a pan [__] or you might get a
show and then they don't they get money
there but they don't want to go do shows
in other cities because there's no bread
but I was like you got to go plant the
flag bro you gotta you gotta build the
fan base you got to go build it I always
tell people like just because you have a
big song doesn't mean you have a big
following this [__] there's people who
have platinum records that can't sell a
[__] concert ticket period like and
that's going to tell you where you're
what fans you really have man is it like
are you actually getting streams because
you have features or are you getting
streams because you have fans that
really love you and then that's going to
translate to those people will come out
and you know support you they'll Buy the
T-shirt
so a lot of that [__] it's a little
pumped up you know what I mean when you
got a lot of features on your records
because you'll see all you don't you
can't sell a hard ticket outside you
can't even sell a hard ticket in your
city you can only get on shows with
[__] I was going to ask you uh
you tell me the story on how you and
Alchemist met and how he became a part
of the uh when he was like 13 I had his
manager
um and today was like hey you want to
make a lot of money and I was like well
when you talk about six or we got this
little rap group
two little white kids from Beverly Hills
you know they get that [__] the [__]
out of here yeah it was James constant
yeah I didn't meet him I didn't see him
I was just like the concept of that [__]
was like were you trying to do like a
crisscross yeah but a white crazy house
of pain I was like
so I think they ended up bringing him to
be real and be real work with them but
then I met Al and I was like oh this is
kid's cool as [__] he reminds me of me
like just like just tenacious [__]
worker like worker and just the love and
the [__] and smart and just work and
work and work and just on point I was
like okay I'm gonna give this kid access
and let him be around and then like I'm
gonna just cut all this [__] you have to
go through and just put you right here
you with the biggest group in the world
now in the studio going on tour hanging
out you know what I mean and just like
give him access because I knew all she
needed to do was be around it he's such
a [__] smart kid and such a sponge
you'll figure it out you know what I
mean just give him access to the [__]
was it um was he always wanting to step
away from rapping and just focus on
producing when I met him he didn't make
beat [__] okay and then when he did that
first time there was they wasn't they
weren't here I mean he was learning yeah
he was really he was a real Premier fan
and and it was just like you know some
c-level Premiere like kid [__] he was
just I'd be like nah that's not it bro
but you knew like I always knew Al has
that that that's it that it thing that
special [__] thing like he's just
[__] whatever Al decided he wanted to do
he was going to be successful in it you
know what I mean he's just that smart
and that [__] that that much of a
hard worker and that got that much Focus
so you know we just
brought him put him under my wing it's
like you know he starts seeing how
records albums are made how Studio
sessions are run you know and the little
tricks the little behind the [__] going
on tour with us carrying the carrying
the crates and shits you know what I
mean you're on [__] big Festival
tours you know I mean at [__] 15
years old
leaving school yeah crazy and then
eventually you know now he's he's
Alchemists grab your nominate God is the
illest in the game right now man I I
agree man I I was just saying like his
like last couple year run has been like
so crazy like you think about the stuff
he's done with boldie with Freddy like
he's just been just Relentless he hasn't
done nothing different he's been working
this hard all these years it just you
know it's just timing it just it's the
perfect storm you know it's like the way
the music is and the way the the uh what
we like
the culture's growing and then just the
right artists at the right times with
all the momentum he's built up over the
years you know what I'm saying I was
gonna ask you um your production process
how much has it changed over the years
because back in the day everybody would
have their go-to equipment nowadays like
I'll like know guys who I never ever
thought would touch like
digital platform like who will only be
on Ableton or they're only Beyond Pro
Tools like what is your yeah it was the
same for me man I was using the sp12 I
moved over to the MPC and then it just I
wanted to do some electronic [__] for
fun and I was like how do you do this
[__] and like oh I can't do it on this
[__] I got to learn this [__]
computer and I was like I was the last
[__] bro to [__] with the
computer like you were hanging on to the
I was hanging on a two inch everything
yeah and I was just like [__] it so I
just took a year and just worked on some
electronic music and just took a year
and just dialed just worked on the
machine until I figured out like oh I
can get my sound out of this thing
because it turned into a lot more um
sound design and then you know getting
into the [__] the the effects yeah
there's plugins for everything yeah and
I haven't haven't not having to have a
big studio and learn everything and
[__] plugging everything in and just
having it right there my fingertips I
was like actually it started getting fun
again for me it's super fun again you
know and then and then my my daughter
got to a certain age where I was like oh
I don't gotta [__] be there all the
time so you know it was like six years
ago is when I was like oh it's about me
again now it's my time kids are raised
shit's all good all right y'all I love
everybody but it's my time I'm gonna be
greedy now it's the most freest I've
ever dive in dive right back in so I
think we've done like you know 34 35
projects in the last six years all right
we got to stop the interview real quick
tell you about our folks at my bookie
our partners at mybookie man listen
football season is approaching it is
preseason right now I can feel it just
had my first Fantasy Draft it's time to
get this [__] money NFL is here go to
mybookie.ag right now sign up for a new
account use the promo code bootleg right
now when you sign up they're gonna give
you that first deposit bonus now my book
is crazy because no matter where you're
at you can go on you get in on some of
that NFL action you can get on some of
that baseball action you can get in on
their Live casino
Blackjack roulette slots whatever you're
into it's going down mybookie.ag all
right sign up right now with that promo
code bootleg they're gonna hook you up
real nice first deposit bonus free money
to gamble with bro when you sign up what
are we talking about football season is
here this is literally my favorite time
of the year as the gentleman we must
participate we got to get a little
action in every Sunday on something
maybe a little Thursday night football
action maybe a little preseason action
who do you think's gonna win the Super
Bowl throw a hundred on it [__] it sign
up mybookie.ag use that promo code
bootleg and they're gonna get you hooked
up with that first deposit bonus also
want to give a big shout out to our
family at King Palm man want to give a
shout out to King Palm they have the um
sugar Sean
first of all congratulations to Phoenix
Arizona's own sugar Shawn for just
winning that title with UFC they did a
collab with them
uh these are the sugar punch honey
orange pre-rolls which are gas all right
now this was dope about King Palm 100
organic all right we're talking about no
tobacco organic leaves and what's dope
is they have these terpene infused tips
that people just love bro they're called
the flavor tips right you're like uh you
bust one of these boys out you know what
I'm saying you fill it with your stuff
whatever you want to smoke some of that
flour that you got from Jardine
and then you hit the tip
and man oh I just tasted it right now
just flavor full of Flavor now go to
kingpom.com right now use the promo code
bootleg and you're gonna get half off
whatever's on kingpop.com if you don't
know King Palm is everywhere go to your
local smoke shop go to your local
7-Eleven they got King Palms everywhere
so many flavors
so many Vibes the grapes are gas
yo kingpom.com use the promo code
bootleg 50 off let's get back to the
interview I was gonna say for you you've
done so many joint projects with artists
if you had to give me I don't want to
don't tell me your favorite but if you
had to give me outside of the Cyber [__]
what's been like two or three that stick
out in your mind in terms of like your
favorite collaborative projects you've
done man it's a lot of them I just enjoy
what I enjoy man is just the working
with people you know you got to be a
cool [__] because um
sit in the [__] studio with you for
two months you know what I mean yeah we
gotta like each other go walk my dog you
know what I'm saying so you know Mayhem
every time I work with Mayhem it's a
[__] blessing he's great you know
what I mean I love working with me man
um TF Rome worthy you know [__] all
these [__] is is cool as [__]
man who's who's um at all the MC's
you've ever worked with
the fastest when it comes to just the
writing process
it used to be it used to be mc8 and then
now I went in with um I went in with
Cassius one time and me and Cassius did
four songs in like a few hours and then
crime Apple came in and did like six
songs and
four hours I think when I first met him
damn
and and what was cool about crime is he
was supposed to go back to New York and
then it was like he came to my radio
show and I was like yo if you want to
come jump in the lab tomorrow
he was I'm supposed to go home but I'm
staying so he stayed did the radio show
and you know now we've done a couple
hours and traveled the world together
that's amazing for you what is what has
changed about
um because being on the road you've seen
kind of all facets of that as well
is it still fun for you to go out and
and do shows and and see the fans in
person yeah I do it more limited you
know like
um I still have a good time though yeah
I just love a good time like because I
don't have to do it but like I like to
do it and so when I want to do it I like
okay this three weeks I'm gonna go do
shows and you know a couple times a year
I'd grab a month and go do some shows yo
when you guys are doing like the early
Cypress Hill [__] where you guys like on
any psychedelics back in the day
Truman what would you say it like
because I don't know if you've noticed
but shrooms are kind of becoming like
other thing right now
we was on that [__] in the 80s man it's
crazy to see it it's like it's like
normalized like it's like people like
are like micro dosing to go to work like
every rapper wants shrooms like yeah I
never seen that coming ever they were
always scared of that [__] you know what
I mean yeah it was it was funny because
even back in the days there was no pills
in the Hood the pills was the the rock
and rollers was [__] with skills
they've never seen pills in the Hood
Ever you know I mean now everybody's
popping pills I mean stay away fentanyl
no there wasn't none of that she was
around we was kids like man nobody we
didn't even see pills man it was just
weed and shrooms what have you ever had
a really bad trip on shrooms no never
had a bad trip that's good
never had a bad trip that's a good thing
because you hear the bad trips is what
scares everybody off yeah they do too
much man you gotta ease into that [__]
you know what I mean just sneeze into it
do a little bit figure out get your get
your foot and figure out what works for
you and do a little bit more and do a
little bit more if you want to go there
otherwise
you know even my first time like I ate
an eighth that's what the homie told you
to do either eighth and you [__] it's
a pretty serious amount it's the [__]
walls are melting you know but I
wouldn't recommend anybody to start with
a full eighth no I wouldn't do that I I
watched a couple years ago when the uh
Mr cartoon Esteban uh documentary came
out I think it was called La Originals
right it's on Netflix everybody should
go watch it because I think it's really
dope like for people to kind of see like
like just both of their come ups and
like how integral and like hip-hop both
of them are I just remember the Mr
cartoon era of rap I just felt like
everyone had the tattoos like
um but for you kind of coming up with
those guys and like you're very much a
part of their story
um how dope was it to see like them get
their flowers with that documentary
check it out man like for me man seeing
my team win is
the dope is [__] for me yeah to see
where they come because all my
[__] is Killers you know look
to see how
you know being 14 years old what he's
doing is like amazing for me to see
cartoons Stefan like
Stefan was working at the door of a club
but I knew him and he wasn't he didn't
get high he was always on point I was
like amen I was like yo I got to I need
a role manager for this new group he
goes with his role manager I go and sees
I'll teach you
um I got this new group called House of
Pain you want to be the role manager he
was like [__] it so he started being the
road manager you know when he was on the
road his dad was like hey son here's a
camera document
time on the road
and then um we'd have photographers
taking pictures that would charge us 30
[__] thousand dollars for some trash
Jesus and I was like
thirty thousand yeah the budgets were
crazy and I was like oh man [__] these
dudes you know what you take the
pictures homie let the homie get the
check
and that's how he started shooting us
wow and that's what the whole soul
assassin [__] was is to build our own
economy and just hire hire each other
anytime we hired these other
[__] and put them in a position
to win they would never come back and
return the favor you know man and those
were the errors that was like the era
where like
babels were just
like getting like they were they were
like like you said a thirty thousand
dollar budget for a photographers insane
right so you would be like you would
always hear these stories about like
labels like you'd get your invoice or
your oh yeah they didn't care they're
spending your money so they don't
spending your money that you have to
recoup and they you know so they know
they're going to recoup because you're
selling four million records so crazy so
you like you said you like a lot of the
[__] you would see on some of these like
spreadsheets you'd be like wait we paid
this much for this like what the [__] a
lot of Voters don't even look I got a
homie that could do it you know what I'm
saying yeah and a lot of artists don't
look they let the managers and
everything in there everybody else is
just as long as they get they cut and
they're just skimming they're getting
paid off top anyways a lot of times they
don't give a [__] but um yeah it was a
lot of that [__] man so and then um you
know so that started happening with
estevon and then um cartoon came along a
little bit later and then you know we
first started letting cartoon do [__]
for us around
our fifth album like rock superstar
album that was the first time you
touched our [__] oh [__] okay yeah but
he was right there with us the whole
time and then you know when I was on
when I go on tour because I met Paul and
then doing we're opening up for M doing
the anger management tour 50 I just came
out within the club so it was 50 exhibit
Eminem Cypress Hill I was uh I went to I
went to that tour did you yeah as I was
a child and I went back I got backstage
and I saw
I met Sophia
Sophia I think was on the road with
exhibit at the time
I think so yeah yeah I think they was
[__] around back in the day yeah and
I was like uh because at the time my
best friend's Brothers
Rocca right so like we had the liquid
Crew He you know Rocco with uh he linked
us with exhibit so we would always be
like oh yeah it's Rock's little brother
yeah so I remember we
sent our ass backstage at the uh Phoenix
tour date of that of that anger
management tour that was a crazy uh so
we bring Cartoon because you know you're
sitting backstage for [__] five six
if you want to get blasted yeah boom
just set him up backstage and he he he
got everybody in that whole tour I think
he did what he was supposed to do yeah
took an opportunity and did what he was
supposed to do absolutely a lot of
[__] get those opportunities
oh I gotta like for the [__]
who won I got a list of fools who just
sat around smoking weed and drinking and
then complaining and complaining
complaining complaining that they didn't
I was like bro put you in this in a
situation I'm not gonna [__] Force
you I'll put you in the game come on run
the ball fool 100 that's it 100 what do
you do outside of Music These Days for
fun for recreation like what is your
workout work out man uh Muay Thai hit
the bags go hiking [__]
um
business yeah like five six different
businesses you know and just [__] um
holidays with the family you know I mean
go shooting just a bunch of different
[__] with the homies
um I just got I want to say last year
I got
um
a bunch of cyber [__] sent to me in the
mail because then you get you guys put
out it was the 30th Anniversary yeah the
anniversary first album yeah I got like
a I think I got a rolling tray I got
like a disposable camera I got a bunch
of cool [__] you guys obviously uh have
been more active recently as a group
um then then in in pastimes um what is
the current situation uh in terms of
like any new music coming out or is that
something that you guys
um me and Bieber recorded I think about
four songs last year but just nothing no
no talks about nothing really right now
you know I mean just a lot of Road [__]
we're putting together
um
uh something called the Cyprus
experience where you come in it'll be
all like future Tech 3D and and you'll
get you know the [__] in those big ass
domes yeah yeah they got one downtown
L.A Wonder Dome yeah I went to um I
think Daft Punk went downtown yeah that
punk had a sick one yeah so putting
something like an immersive disciples
experience that'd be fire type I want to
take what they're doing a step further
and you know have it um
have um have a 3D and and have it take
you to um a little little metaverse is
it crazy like to see your guys's because
I was thinking about this the other day
because I'm like you guys have so many
like crazy stories and like wrinkles to
your guys's careers as a group and also
just solo wise
would you guys ever do like a Netflix or
Straight Outta Compton type of movie but
surrounding Cyprus so the thing maybe a
series or something what we're talking
about is the solar assassins because
then I could tell in that I could tell a
full Cypress story and I could tell a
full mug story and a b-real and a
Alchemist in a cartoon yeah Stefan and
you know everything else so I think that
would be something I think that can even
go further yeah that'd be crazy but yeah
we're in the process right now working
with Sony on an animated series
oh [__] that'd be crazy that's dope man
it's been dope to just see you you just
turn it up be reals turning up doing
dope content too like it's just been
dope to see man so uh the new album is
out Soul assassin's three Death Valley
the movie is is the movie on YouTube
yeah no the movie drops on the 13th okay
yeah yeah September 13th um probably on
Amazon where I'm
where I'm doing screenings all month New
York San Francisco Chicago I just did I
just did on Tokyo they're going to
screen it in Europe so just screening
the whole the movie all month you guys
got a big fan base in in Japan right
crazy it's crazy crazy yeah there's
something crazy like I I just watched
this YouTube video
like there's something about your like
parts of Japan where they're just like
extremely infatuated with LA culture oh
one thousand percent when they you
wouldn't they look like they look like
the homies low riders and everything you
wouldn't even know they think it's the
homie from East L.A right so you talk to
them you know what I mean
but yeah and when they do something bro
they refine it they refine it they
refine it to its simplest form and they
Master the [__] out of it and end up
doing it better than you that's great
it's their appreciation for everything
they do man they just sit back and watch
and refine the [__] out of it even the
fashion even their cotton even there
um
everything the [__] they do yeah so
September 13th December 13th movie well
hey what which uh verse on this album
did you have to wait the longest for
Slick Rick Slick Rick about a year I had
to guess Slick Rick or Scarface would be
my guess Buddy's face was knocked it out
in a week really bomb shout out to
Scarface
shout out to Brad Jordan man that guy
was like damn the quickest [__] hit me
on the phone that mugs what do you want
what are we going for on this and I told
him he was like okay I got you and then
boom send it like two days later that's
fire man anything um
um coming out or anything that's in the
can in terms of uh collab albums I'm
sure you got a few that that are already
finished yeah we got like about 16
projects in the work right now but we're
gonna drop first of the year is going to
be um Mayhem record in the TF record
those are going to probably be the first
projects coming out
like February February February March
okay be on the lookout for those go get
the album the album is The Who's Who of
just hip-hop my goodness yeah they all
murdered that [__] too man you know you
got a crazy lineup of man the track
listing is unbelievable in 2023. yeah
yeah so you delivered man thank you
brother appreciate it thanks for having
me up here man the legend you yes fire
brother man I appreciate you too 100 hey
what up man uh you just watched another
episode of the blue black cat podcast
brought to you by hard Dean baby shout
out to the family at hardean don't
forget
make sure if you're in Las Vegas you get
into that taxi as soon as you land you
get into that Uber say take me to
hardine all right they're gonna take get
you taken care of the most craziest
Premium Selection of cannabis you'll
ever find Under One Roof it's a vibe in
there the bud tenders they're gonna take
care of you man listen tell them I sent
you they're gonna get you right shout
out to the family at hardine in Las
Vegas the number one dispensary in the
world all right and we are so proud to
be partners with them so shout out to
hardine go follow them online Harding
underscore Las Vegas and check out their
website hardinglasvegas.com get you some
swag you know you can't buy this but you
know yeah shout out to hardine